a teenage girl found an iPhone in an
airplane bathroom and it was an iPhone
underneath the seat or behind the seat
to basically catch her naked and this
was after a flight attendant a male
flight attendant on I think it was
American Airlines told her hey come up
to the use the bathroom in the first
class cabin and then he was in there
first then she goes in uses the bathroom
then she sees him go back in there
presumably to take this iPhone the
family is extremely Disturbed as well
they should be my my thought on this is
I mean I hope the family sues I hope
this guy goes the guy ended up getting
arrested apparently once the plane
landed but my main thought on this other
than just revulsion and disgust is how
many things had to go wrong in this
guy's life how many bad turns did this
guy have to take to get to the point
where he was planting a camera in an
airplane bathroom for a 14 year old girl
to film her in states of undress in a
kind of disgusting states of unrest too
because you're in a bathroom